[Music]
solomon is with us in arizona hi solomon
how are you
good thanks dave for taking my call sure
what's up
um so i was calling i'm in uh baby step
two i have about 32 well me and my wife
have about 32
000 and baby step two
um household income we have about 80 to
82 000
um but my question is about our house
situation
so my wife um bought her house that we
live in
um about seven years ago she was in dire
need
and she got into a rent to home
situation
and
we pay 6.75 a month
180 goes towards the principal of the
house the 495 is considered rent
so what i'm wondering is they said we
could pay it off
you know if we get a mortgage or
whatever
we can pay it off
and go through
like a single bank
or
do we just write it out as it is
okay what is what is the payoff on the
contract now
um
last i checked which was a couple years
ago it was 53 000. what's the house
worth
probably as it fits probably close to a
hundred
okay what's your household homework done
um 80 to 82.
okay
yeah i'd run down to the credit union
and just get a 50 000 loan
and put the house into your name
um the reason is hey you're gonna lose
all this equity if you lose this deal
and uh so the never do rent to own never
do a land contract or contract for deed
which is what this is okay
the reason is the house is not in your
name
if the current owner gets in trouble
you lose everything
and there's nothing you can do about it
so let's let's say he was let's say he
was in a car wreck and got sued
for 500 000 for wrongful death it goes
as a lien against his property this
property is not in your name it's in his
name
all right
you would like i don't know what you
lose an actual owner i think it goes i
think a company the company that we pay
to i think they buy these houses if that
company gets in trouble and has a lien
put on sales you would lose the house
the point is you are paying
payments as if you own it you're acting
like you've got 50 000 worth of equity
and the house is not in your name
right right you don't own it very
dangerous
now as far as like i like even though
i'm in you know
um baby step two my credit i have pretty
good credit
um as far as the store my wife doesn't
she doesn't have any debts or anything
the point is you're gonna go down to a
local credit union anyway right and
they're going to look at the whole
situation they're going to look at the
fact that you're buying this house at 50
cents on the dollar because it's a rent
to own
right you're buying it for 50 000.
they're going to get a 50 000 loan on a
100 000 property that's pretty safe for
them
okay okay and they look at an eighty
thousand dollar income
to pay a tiny little loan like this
i mean some people making eighty
thousand by fifty thousand dollar cars
i don't recommend that but my point is
is that
your income is very large for this deal
wonderfully large okay and there's 50
000 worth of equity protecting them so
credit union will make this loan
okay
yeah you guys need to go get this house
in your name even if you don't keep the
house even if you turn around and sell
it
right
because you're gonna you're you're in a
very precarious and dangerous situation
with the property not being in your name
now i know we normally don't recommend
you buy a house while you're in baby
step two while you're in debt but in
effect here you've already bought a
house you've just done it poorly in a
sense we're refinancing in a sense here
yeah i'm seeing a lot of these pop up
now dave with this way the real estate
market's been there's a lot of slick
online companies that are saying hey
it's basically a rent to own scenario so
that you can get into this house sooner
because you don't have any money never
do that so i want to steer people away
from those i've been getting messages
going hey is this a good idea no
don't do it quick answer no save up a
down payment do another move to the
capitol no yeah oh don't do it